welcome to hannity tonight another
bombshell new report surrounding new
york governor andrew cuomo
according to late breaking news tonight
from the new york times cuomo's
associates
waged a smear campaign against his first
accuser the first of seven
only days after her allegations became
public
so is andrew cuomo going to be held
accountable by the i believer caucus
we'll bring you that important update
straight ahead we'll also have full
coverage of the
growing crisis it is a crisis it's real
on our southern border where four
suspected terrorists have been
arrested while trying to cross illegally
into this country including three
individuals from
yemen minority leader kevin mccarthy
will be here with an update
and unlike joe biden who doesn't even
seem to realize there's a crisis
mccarthy actually visited the border
we'll show you some of that videotape
but first with razor thin
majorities in the u.s house and the
senate
now democrats are attempting to
implement what will be the single
largest biggest power grab in modern
american political history as we speak
there is now a full court press to
abolish
the legislative filibuster in the united
states senate
look at what joe biden just said earlier
tonight in an interview for abc and
georgie stephanopoulos
i know you've been reluctant to do away
with the filibuster aren't you gonna
have to choose
between preserving the filibuster and
advancing your agenda
yes but here's the choice i don't think
you have to eliminate the filibuster you
have to
do it what it used to be when i first
got to the senate back in the old days
when you used to be around there and
that is that a filibuster you had to
stand up and command the floor
and you had to keep talking alone you
couldn't call for you know
they no no one could say you know quorum
call
once you stop talking you lost that and
someone could move in and say
i moved the question of so you got to
work for the filibuster
so you're for that reform you're for
bringing back the talking filibuster i
am
that's what it was supposed to be now
well joe wants to make it harder for the
filibuster
most democrats want to do away with it
completely
they know that this socialist utopia
vision they have for america is insane
they know their radical bills will never
get the 60 votes needed to clear the
filibuster proof majority in the senate
so now
they'll just change the rules according
to the top democrats
we're now hearing tonight the filibuster
is incredibly important when republicans
are in power
but now the democrats are in charge it
must be abolished and abolished
immediately
said they could just pass anything and
everything they want and ram it down the
country's throat take a look
what about that nuclear option doing
away with the filibuster
well i can tell you that would be the
end of the senate as it was originally
devised and created going back to our
founding fathers today's filibuster is
often used to prevent the senate from
even starting to debate important ideas
it's not the guarantor of democracy it
has become the death grip
of democracy i said let's not do the
supreme court
we should have 60 votes which we still
do
because we should get bipartisan support
we hope our republican colleagues will
work with us to produce that change
we will try to get them to work with us
but if not
we will put our heads together and
figure out how to go and everything is
on the table
the point is we still left the 60 votes
in place right for the supreme court
and mitch mcconnell changed that i would
prefer to bring it back we are where we
are
and now i don't think anyone's going to
want to the hamstring themselves
i favor getting rid of the filibuster i
think we have too much we have to do for
this country
amazing what a couple years can do when
you're in charge
here's what you need to know about the
democratic party it is filled with now
the most radical far-left individuals of
any major political party in modern
political history
their only real principle is power over
everything over the constitution
over the bill of rights over the rule of
law over basic fairness
and justice they want one party ruled
they want it in perpetuity
forever and ever now their plan to
achieve this goal does consist of three
main parts
number one kill the filibuster number
two
pass h.r one with a simple majority
that's the bill that would expand
voting to convicted felons eliminate all
voter id
whatsoever laws automatically register
everybody in the country and expand
massively mail-in voting in other words
hr one creates
an election system way more susceptible
to fraud and abuse and ballot harvesting
a dreamlike scenario for this modern
power hungry democratic socialist party
make no mistake the bill is not only
unconstitutional
it federalizes the implementation of
elections
it asserts the stated power given to
state legislatures
that is reserved for them and that's
where step three comes into play
they want court packing and as we
predicted top democrats now want to
expand and then pack the u.s supreme
court
and lower courts with far-left activists
who will rubber-stamp their
their radical agenda in late january
less than a week after getting sworn in
joe biden started a commission
to figure out how to get all of that
done that would be a doomsday scenario
not just for the gop but for the entire
country
one party democratic rule always ends in
the same
with the same results higher taxes more
poverty
rampant corruption broken promises oh
and they want to make d.c
and puerto rico a state so they think
they'll have four democratic senators
added in perpetuity look at new york
look at new jersey
look at illinois look at california
because that's what they want america to
look like
unfortunately we you the american people
you can stop this from happening
especially if you live in west virginia
or arizona
those two people right there two
democratic senators
kristen sinema joe manchin they have
recently come out against ending the
legislative filibuster
those two senators follow through with
their promise the filibuster will remain
in place the very one democrats were
demanding or also would destroy the
senate
but unfortunately joe manchin looks like
he's beginning to buckle
when pressured by new york's chuckie
schumer so
if you're from west virginia if you're
from arizona you might want to call you
might want to write you might want to
email
i suggest you be polite but let your
voices be heard
because once that filibuster is gone the
party that puts power over everything
they will now rule life pretty much
forever